what is your expectation for changes in
regulation or disclosures coming out of
kind of all of the last couple of weeks
and the chaos in the crypto Market
I I think that the centralized players
are under regulated now the the issue
here is we need to be very careful about
what works and what doesn't and kind of
where the dividing line should be
because when it comes to the
decentralized lending protocols you
could watch some of these liquidations
happen on chain in real time as they are
happening uh during the liquidity crisis
a couple of weeks ago the prices were
you know getting uh getting drawn down
and um and that's painful for whoever's
taking out a margin position on chain
but the protocols worked right and I
think some of that is kind of missing
here the real issues were in the
centralized uh black boxes
that's out on top of this and and we're
basically you know holding themselves
out to be these uh these really robust
uh you know banks with good risk
controls and and you know really strong
products they'll run by professional
teams when in reality you know they're
basically you know under reserves banks
with poor risk controls even if they
were defrauded you know some of these
companies to have 50 of your outstanding
loan book be with one counterparty I
mean that's just piss poor risk
management right there's there's no
other way to to slice it no matter how
big three arrows was uh in in terms of
you know it's it's import as an industry
player so I think that's
um that's one of the things that's going
to be hard that's going to be a bell
that can't get on wrong right and and I
I think that
um regulating centralized entities
um is important and in fact most people
that are serious in the industry talk
about the need to regulate the
centralized entities here that are
handling customer funds that are making
markets and that are facilitating
lending or exchange right I don't know
anyone serious that's arguing against
that what the issue is going to be is
where do we draw the line and can we
ensure that some of the open protocols
and peer-to-peer Financial activity you
know like on-chain lending or like
decentralized exchange is is not touched
and it's it's you know thoughtful and
vigorously defended so it's not thrown
out with the bath water
um when we when we start to see some
more stringent regulations on the
centralized entities
um and if we do our jobs right you know
kind of collectively as an industry I
think that's where we'll end up or the
peer-to-peer will
um will be protected uh and the
centralized entities that look like Bank
to regulated like Banks centralized
exchanges that operate like New York
Stock Exchange and and you know NASDAQ
they're regulated as such
um and you know that'll ultimately usher
in the the next you know wave of growth
and institutional adoption so I think
everybody wins if we can get that
balance right